[موسيقى]
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيات وانا راويه
العالمي
[موسيقى]
من اسبوعين تقريبا قبل نشر هاي الحلقه
اجريت اول محاوله بشريه للسيطره على الشمس
نعم السيطره على الشمس بالمفهوم العريض
طبعا ولكن نظريا وفي جوهرها هذا بالفعل ما
تحاول فعله
فكره تثير الرعب لمجرد التفكير فيها صح
في نهايه المطاف مين احنا البشر لمسيطر
على النجم المركزي في مجموعتنا الشمسيه
واهم مصدر طاقه وشريان الحياه الاساسي على
كوكبنا
هذا النجم اللي بيبلغ 119 حجم كوكب الارض
هذا الكوكب اللي احنا جميعا كجنس بشري
بالكاد نسكن 10% فقط من مساحته كامله
شايفين الصوره معي والتفاوت الهائل
بالاحجام
يعني هو الموضوع مش بالضبط هيك المهم شركه
بيئيه
الغروب بدات بالفعل بنشر جزيئات ثاني
اكسيد الكبريت او الصوفر في الطبقات
العليا من الغلاف الجوي لتكوين سحابه
قادره على عكس اشعه الشمس للفضاء الخارجي
بعيدا عن الارض والهدف تبريد درجه حراره
الارض ولو قيد ام له
وهذا الاجراء على فكره بيندرج تحت ما يسمى
بالهندسه الجيولوجيه
وبهذا وفي حال نجاح التجارب للسيطره على
ما يصلنا من اشعه الشمس واعتماد هذا الحل
عالميا لتفادي كارثه بيئيه متصاعده يوم
بعد يوم ممكن نكون قادرين على تغيير قدر
كوكبنا اللي بدانا بتشكيله بايدينا من
تقريبا 300 عام منذ الثوره الصناعيه في
منتصف القرن الثامن عشر
التجربه اجريت على نطاق ضيق جدا وباستخدام
منهجيه غير متطوره وما كانت مدعومه من اي
جهه حكوميه امريكيه لكنه بحسب مجله
كانت على الاغلب اول محاوله حقيقيه على
ارض الواقع لفعل شيء كهذا كثير من
الانتقادات طالت الشركه اللي بتفصح على
موقعها الرسمي على الانترنت انه هاي
الطريقه ناجعه للغايه بحيث انه جرام واحد
من السحب التي تنتجها باستطاعته انه يحيد
التاثير السلبي على البيئه وارتفاع درجات
حراره الارض اللي بيخلفه طن كامل من
انبعاثات ثاني اكسيد الكربون لمده سنه
وبتكلفه ما بتشكل تخيلوا واحد بالميه من
تكلفه حلول الاحتباس الحراري الاخرى
لغايه الان هذا كلام رائع واذا صح هذا
يعني احنا وجدنا الحل السحري لمشكله بتهدد
وجودنا فعليا اذا لماذا كل هذه الانتقادات
والاجابه تكمل في انه الامر ليس بهذه
السهوله وككل خطوه بخطوها الجنس البشري
للرفاهيه والتقدم هناك ثمن يجب علينا دفعه
فالسؤال الاصح هون ما هو بالضبط هذا الثمن
على كل حال الشركه بتصر على المضيق دوما
في تجاربها رغم كل هذه الانتقادات واللي
طالت جهودها السابقه في مجال الهندسيه
الجيولوجيه
قبل ما نكمل سرد التفاصيل متابعينا الكرام
بحب ارحب بضيفي من بيروت دكتور دوميت كامل
رئيس خبراء حمايه الصحه والبيئه العالميه
والمستشار الدولي والمرجع البيئي لشؤون
البيئه والمناخ اهلا وسهلا فيك دكتور
هل يمكن ان يكون
الموضوع
الشمس من خلال الهندسه الجيولوجيه الشمسيه
هو خيارنا الاخير الاخير او يعني او
لبلاند بي ام انه احنا عملنا نتغاضى همم
عن حلول اخرى ممكن تكون اقل قرار همم او
على الاقل احنا نقدر نتوقع تبعاتها اكثر
بكثير من موضوع التحكم باشعه الشمس اللي
بتصل للارض وكل هذا طبعا درجات حراره
الارض اكيد
جدا
والنتيجه راح تكون خطيره بكل تاكيد لانه
لدراسه الاسره البيئي متشاغبه جدا
واختار كثير عاليه
بس يدفع ثمن كوكب الارض هالموضوع بكل
تاكيد بكل تاكيد لحد اليوم اعتبارا من سنه
ال 85 وال90 في دراسات وابحاث عديده جدا
مع العلم انه معظم القيادات البيئيه
بالعالم رفضت هذا المشروع رفضلي والخطر
الاكبر والخطر الاكبر انه نتائج النتائج
من دراسه الاثر بي او دراسه او النتائج
الاثر البيئه الى المشروع امبارح تكون
خطيره على كوكب الارض ورا الدايره هنشوف
نتائج
مسببه
لكويرس على سطح هذا الكوكب لانه نحن
عايشين على كوكب طائر المشكله الوقود
الاحفوري ياللي عم بسبب عم بيسبب كميات
ضخم من السوق ورده والغازات الدفيئه جديد
كل سنه عم بيزداد عن السنه الماضيه بمعنى
انه نحنا المشكله
الموجوده رحنا المشكله دي مشكله اخرى
بنعرف نتائجها نتائجها بعد عشر سنين او 20
سنه
كميات الهطول الامطار للثلوج ايضا
الزراعه
الامراض تاثير السلبي للكائنات الحيه ككل
تاثير السلبي لحيات الانسان ماذا تاثيره
الخطير جدا على على طبقه الاوزون
ومشتقاتها يعني نحن رايحين نشتغل نعمل بكل
تاكيد خطير جدا راح نفصل كل هذه الاثار
بشكل دقيق بعد شوي بس قبل هيك حبيت اسالك
همم عن التجربه الوحيده على ما يبدو
العمليه اللي اجريها حتى لان هي شركه
صغيره
اه ميك صن سيتي عملت هذه التجربه
بالولايات المتحده طبعا ملاتها على نطاق
ضيق جدا همم يمكن راح يكون لها اي تابعات
ولكن تعتبر هاي اول مره بتم فيها اجراء
مثل هذه التجربه الشركه ميكسنس سيتس على
الويب سايد الرسمي تبعها موقع الرسمي على
الانترنت بتقول بانه همم هي هي الطريقه
اللي هي جيو انجلينا او الهندسه
الجيولوجيه
المهندسه المنام هي الطريقه الناجعه
للغايه لانه همم جرام واحد جرام واحد فقط
من الصحب اللي بتنتجها همم وهي السحب اللي
راح تعكس اشعه الشمس الى خارج الى الفضاء
الخارجي باستطاعته باستطاعته هذا الجرام
انه يحيد تاثير السلبي على البيئه وارتفاع
درجات حراره الارض اللي بيخلفه طن كامل من
انبيعاتها ثاني اكسيد الكربون لمده سنه
وكل هذا عم بيسي ممكن انه نعمله بتاكله في
شكل واحد بالميه من تكلفه حلول الاحتباس
الحراري الاخرى هل دقيق هذا الوصف هل
بالفعل هاي التكنولوجي على الاقل من ناحيه
نظريه قادره على تحقيق اللي بتقول عنه او
ما تزعمه هاي الشركه
بكل تاكيد اللي بدي اقوله الحياه الكوكب
كل حياه الموجوده على سطح القمر على سطح
الارض هي اساس الشمس
هو الشمس الا الاساس الاساس وجوده واساس
حمايته يعني اليوم المزروعات بدها بدها
اشعه الشمس فبتاخد فيتاميناتها من اشعه
الشمس هذا الانسان مزبوط بس دكتور يعني
هذه الطريقه مش رح تعكس اشعه الشمس كامله
هي جزء من اشعه الشمس رح تحاول تخفف درجات
الحراره انا اللي حابه افهمه انه هل هذا
الزعم نظريا ممكن يكون صحيح على الاقل هل
هي قادره على ذلك والمشكله في المبيعات
انا بدي اشدد على نقطه من عيني اول شيء
برجع هي الحياه على سطح هذا الكوكب
تخفيض الشمس
يؤثر على الجنيه كل كل المخلوقات على صفحه
العمل
معظم النباتات بدها تاخذ كل كل الفيتا وكل
الحياه من الشمس ما في نباتات بتعيش بدون
شمس
بدون شمس الحياه الحياه
مرتب الشمس
نحن حرام نلعب حرام نلعب بمصير الكوكب كله
حرام نلعب بمصيره يعني اليوم نحن الخوف
الاكبر اذا الشمس
عنا مناطق جليديه راح يصير في عنا مناطق
هطول امطار بشكل بشكل فيضانات وسيول خطيره
جدا رح يكون في مناطق فيها جفاف بشكل كامل
جدا راح في مناطق رح تفقد الحياه في
البحيره المحيطات والبحار راح تتاثر طبقه
الاوزون بكل تاكيد راح تتاثر بحوده كيف
طيب انا يعني اسفه اني قاطعتك انا بس كنت
حابه انك تبقى معنا شوي خليني اكمل سرد
التفاصيل
لمتابعينا الكرام وبنرجع بنتابع الحديث
لكن القصه لم تبدا هنا مع جهود ميكس
لتخفيض درجات حراره الارض بل ربما هنا
تنتهي
والمشكله لا تكمن في هذه الشركه وتجاربها
بل يبدو انها اعمق من هيك بكثير فكره
الهندسه الجيولوجيه بتعود لعقود من الزمن
ولكنها جماعه سخن كبير في الفتره الاخيره
لدرجه انه اكاديميات العلوم والهندسه
والطب ومؤسسات امريكيه اخرى طلبت بتسريع
الابحاث في هذا المجال وهذا دفع
الاكاديميه الوطنيه للعلوم في امريكا
للتوصيه برسم ميزانيه تقدر بما بين 100
الى 200 مليون دولار على مدى الخمس سنوات
القادمه لفهم جدول تعظيم الشمس واخطار
الاثار الجانبيه الغير متعمده لذلك
والاهم كيف يمكن التحكم بالتكنولوجيا
المرتبطه بهذه الهندسه الجيولوجيه بطريقه
اخلاقيه
لتوضيح فقط الهندسه الجيولوجيه هي
المعالجه المتعمده واسعه النطاق لا احدى
العمليات البيئيه الي بتاثر على مناخ
الارض في محاوله للتصدي لاثار الاحتباس
الحراري او هذا على الاقل هو تعريفها
بالمعنى العام اما التحكم بما يصلنا من
اشعه الشمس فيسمى بالهندسه الجيولوجيه
الشمسيه او الهندسه البيئيه الشمسيه سولار
وتحديدايشن او تعديل الاشعاع الشمسي
والفكره في الاساس مستوحاه من الطبيعه
نفسها بعد رصد تداعيات ثوران البراكين
اللي بتفجرها بتدفع بجزيئات كبريتيه
وكيمياويه اخرى الى الجو وبتشكل سحابه
بركانيه ضخمه قادره في بعض الاحيان على
حجب الشمس لا اشعر وتغيير المناخ ودرجات
الحراره
ولكن كما هو الحال مع اي فكره جديده او
تقدم تكنولوجي على قدر الدعم والموافقه
تكون عاده المعارضه والانتقادات وفي حاله
الهندسه الجيولوجيه موجه المعارضه في
الاوساط العلميه والسياسيه لا يمكن
الاستهانه فيها مش فقط في الولايات
المتحده بل في اوروبا واستراليا والجدل
حول العالم مستمر
بحيث تعتبر هذه الجهات ان هذا التلاعب في
الهندسه الشمسيه ممكن يكون خطير وممكن
يؤدي الى عواقب وخيمه تتخطى اي فائده يمكن
ان تتحقق من خلالها ولهذا السبب طالب اكثر
من 400 عالم مخضرم ومتخصص في علوم الارض
والعلوم السياسيه حول العالم في مطلع هذا
العام عام 2023
بتوقيع اتفاقيه دوليه لحظر استخدام
الهندسه الجيولوجيه الشمسيه بشكل كامل
برزق الاعتراضات على استخدام هذه
التكنولوجيا تكمل في انه لا يمكن باي شكل
من الاشكال توقع تبيعات تعديم الشمس على
كافه بقاع الكوكب فممكن انها تؤدي الى
نتائج محموده في منطقه ما ونتائج كارثيه
في منطقه اخرى
اما لو سالته مداخل السياسي في كل هذا لا
تجعل خبراء علم السياسه كمان يعترض عليها
الجواب بسيط وهو غياب نظام حكم موحد نهايه
التكنولوجيا او ببساطه من ما هي الجهه الي
رح تحدد متى واين وباي قدر يمكن استخدامها
التكنولوجيا فجمي سكان الارض رح يتاثروا
بذلك ولكن ليس بطريقه متساويه على الاطلاق
والتواصل الاجتماعي
التكنولوجيا تقريبا شبه مستحيل وابرز مثال
على ذلك ما فعلته السويد في منتصف العام
الماضي عام 2022 لما اوقفت تجربه ضيقه
النطاق كانت التنميه جامعه الامريكيه
اجراءها لنشر معدات في منطقه سويديه بهدف
اطلاق كميه ضئيله من مواد معتمه للشمس بعد
ما اعترض عليها السكان الاصليين في
المنطقه
وبالتالي بغياب قانون دولي او حتى محلي
بيحكم هذه المساله بيصبح العالم اشبه
بحاره كل من ايده الو كما يقال بالعاميه
فيما يتعلق بالهندسه الجيولوجيه فكما ورد
في احد مقالات الراي في بلومبرج لا يوجد
قانون او معاهده دوليه بتمنع الشركات
الخاصه من العبث واجراء التجارب في مجال
الهندسيه الجيولوجيه فما بالك بافراد
بيملكوا ثروات بتفوق ميزانيه الدول
اللي بالمناسبه من اشد الداعمين لهذا الحل
وكان من ابرز الممولين لتجربه جامعه هارت
واللي للاسف لم يكتب لها النور
نرجع لموضوعنا دكتور
هناك على حسب علمي وحسب البحث اللي عملته
ثلاث مبادرات دوليه في هذا الاطار فيما
يتعلق بالهندسه البيئيه والشمسيه
وحده تابعه لا مؤتمر باريس او تحت مظله
مؤتمر باريس للمناخ وواحده اسمها مبادره
للامم المتحده وفي مبادره دغريز او درجات
وهي في المملكه المتحده وين وصلت الجهود
الذي دراسه اصلا بغض النظر عن يعني
تبيعاتها السلبيه راح نفصلها بعد قليل
ولكن وين وصلت الجهود لدراسه همم يعني مثل
هذا الاجراء وهل ما زالت نظريه بحته بما
انه بس شركه واحده صغيره اللي هي ماك اللي
قدرت تعمل همم
تجربه عمليه في هذا الايطالي
كل المؤسسات الي حكيتي عنهم هن الخوف
الاكل الخوف الاكبر عندهم من دراسات دقيقه
جدا من دراسه الاثر البيئي والخوف الاكبر
من النتائج يعني اليوم اطلع من الشغل يعني
هذا الموضوع هذا هو حياه كوكب الارض عم
نلعب بالنتائج كوكب الارض نتائجها عالي هل
راح تكون تاثيره على كل الكائنات الحيه
بما فيها البشر والنبات هون الموضوع موضوع
كثير خطير يعني خلينا نحنا نرجع اذا بدنا
نفكر علميا بموضوع ناجح جدا نحن عم ناخذ
هالبترول من قلبها عم نحرق هالكوكب بايدنا
بما معنى نحن عم نحرق كل يوم 100 مليون
برميل
او راحوا المواد هايدي هايدي غير متجدده
الخطر الاكبر انه عم يحرقون وبي فتره وبي
فتره طويله جدا
بسيطه جدا رح نوصل لمرحله
اه نلاقي كميات البترول المطلوبيه يوميا
مريت كميات الوقود المطلوبه
وسائل البديله للطاقه او مصادر بديله
للطاقه اهمها الطاقه الشمسيه
ولذلك اليوم نحن المفروض نبلش بالوقود
بالبحث عن الطاقه النظيفه عن ابطال
الشمس
من علماء البيئه بالعالم
يعرف وين اي حيدر ما راح نقدر ندمر الكوكب
نحن بايدنا وندمر الحياه على سطح هذا
الكوكب وما بنعرف انا بدي اقوله اكثر من
هيك هل كميات المره تنكب بنجاوب شو راح
اتاثر على حركه الرياح شو راح اتاثر على
حركه على ضوء القمر شو راح اتاثر على على
امور كثيره الكتل الهوائيه الموجوده
على تدمير طبقه الاوزون
اول شيء ذكرت انت الكائنات الحيه في عندنا
نباتات وطبعا معروف لانه الشمسيه اهم مصدر
لا مهمه جدا للتمثيل الكلوروفيل اللي
بيصير داخل النباتات وبالتالي همم وهذا
باثر على جوده الطعام اللي عم ناكله همم
شو راح يصير شو ممكن يصير بالنسبه
للعالم كله كله من قيادات البيئيه بالعالم
تعرفها
اذا اخذنا اذا اخذنا نبته البندوره نبته
البندوره بتاخذ اشعه الشمس من خلال اوراقه
ومن خلال اوراق بتاخذ الفيتامينات
المطلوبه وبتعمل لها بعمليه بعمليه معقده
جدا من خلال اشعه الشمس بتصير بتصير
الفيتامينات موجوده براس البندوره اذا
هشيت لي اذا بندوره ما شافت الشمس
فاكهه على اختلاف انواعها كل هذه الفاكهه
كل كل كل كل كل الماكولات بالعالم مصدر
الرئيسي الى انتاجها هو يقطاع الشمسيه
الفيتامينات تتغر منها نعم في عندنا في
عندنا كثير كبيره اذا بدي اشرحها
هالطريقه اللي معقده جدا هالطريقه المؤقته
جدا باعطي مثل البسيط النباتات الموجوده
كلها الحيوانات الاليفه بتدخل بتتخمر
بتتخمر بامعاء الحيوانات الاليفه
وبترجع بتطلع شيء منها الابقار بنحطها
بترجع بتقطع ما بتقبض تنحط لها الشجره
بترجع الفيتامينات تفوت تدخل منها السيمات
على بتمتص الشجره وبتصير واصله لاصله
لعندك للسمر تبعها اذا هالعمليات هذه كلها
شلنا شلنا ضربنا الانتاج العالمي شو بنعمل
اذا ضربنا الفيتامينات
اذا طلبنا اذا اذا رفضنا اذا دمرنا
بالاحرى اذا دمرنا كل الانتاج الزراعي
والانتاج النباتي
الانسان شو وين بيعيش هل يمكن لانه يعيش
الانسان
ياكل من فيلم فيديو
ولا ممكن اكثر اكثر هل مياه الامطار هتكون
هتصير عندنا امطار امطار كيميائيه باخطار
كثير عاليه ما بنعرف نتائجها هذا سؤال بده
دراسه واسعه
بندرس بندرس الامور بيقع بكثير الف مره
لا يعني تنحصر فقط همم كوارث بيئيه راح
تصير ورح نخل توازن كوكبنا بشكل كامل ولكن
ايضا احنا نفسنا كمخلوقات راح ندفع ثمن
كبير سواء انسان او اي نوع اخر من
المخلوقات ذكرت
انما كل الكائنات الحيه كل الكائنات الحيه
اما بالنسبه لاجهزه الامم المتحده فهل
يمكن انها تلعب دور الحاكم لاستخدام
التكنولوجيا الجواب هو انه هاي الاجهزه
تفتخر لتفويض العام اللي ممكن يخولها
للقيام بها هاي المهمه بينما مجلس الامن
الدولي ممكن يشكل جهه حاكمه ذات اشكاليات
جمع في هذا الايطار فاي قرار يوضع على
الطاوله مجلس الامن يمكن بكل سهوله
اعتراضه باستخدام حق الفيتو من قبل اي من
اعضاء الخمس الدائمين وهي بالمناسبه ولا
سخريه القدر اكثر الدول تلويثا لهذا
الكوكب
وايضا التقاء مصالح الدول الكبرى واتفاقها
على منهجيه واحده هو اقرب للخيال منه الى
الحقيقه وطبعا قلنا في القرارات السياسيه
حتى ذات الابعاد الانسانيه منها واللي تم
ايقافها في مجلس الامن فيها اسوه في ذلك
وفي غياب قوانين دوليه بتحكم هذا التخصص
احتماليه نشوب حروب كمان بسبب الهندسه
الجيولوجيه راح تبقى وارده وبشده تخيلوا
مثلا لو قررت الهند ضخ كميات كبيره من
الكبريت في طبقات الغلاف الجوي وكانتيجه
لذلك راح تجتاح باكستان المجاوره موجوده
فيضانات او حتى جفاف ممكن يؤدي الى خطر
المجاعه فكروا فيها دولتين نوويتين مثل
الهند وباكستان بيجمعهم عادات تاريخي
وتوتر مزمن في العلاقات واحداهما مقتنعه
انه الاخرى اعتدت عليها وعلى شعبها بهذه
الطريقه
شو راح تكون النتيجه كمان انت تتخيلوا
حقيقه الامر انه احنا لا نملك يقين لما
يتعلق الامر بمناخ الارض ومستقبله سوى
يقين واحد فقط وهو انه كوكبنا بيقبع على
صفيح ساخن حرفيا مع ارتفاع معدل درجات
الحراره عالميا اكثر من درجه مئويه واحده
عن معادلاتها قبل الثوره الصناعيه مما
يقرب من 300 عام والعامه الناس للاسف هذا
الارتفاع ما بدق ناقوس الخطر بنهايه
المطاف كيف راح تاثر الدرجه مئويه واحده
او حتى درجتين علينا ولكن من لا يرى هذا
تاثير الكبير المتمثل في موجات حر غير
مسبوقه فيضانات تاريخيه في كثير من الدول
وجفاف انهار عمرها بعمر الارض وجفاف وفشل
في المحاصيل الزراعيه ومجاعات وذوبان
للجليد في قطبي الارض وارتفاع مستوى مياه
البحار وغرق مناطق كامله كانت ماهوله
لعقود من لا يرى كل ذلك فهو للاسف اعمى
المجتمع الدولي حاول التصدي لهذا المصير
المظلم وتدارك ما يمكن تداركه وضع حد
الارتفاع المتزايد هذا من خلال اتفاقيه
باريس للمناخ عام 2016
عليها بضبط الارتفاع في معدل درجات حراره
الارض لاقل من درجتين مئويتين اعلى من
معدلها قبل الثوره الصناعيه وجعل هذا
الارتفاع يتوقف عند درجه ونصف فقط وطريقه
لفعل ذلك بحسب الاتفاقيه هي تخفيض
الانبعاثات الكربونيه وغاز الميثان عن
طريق استبدال مصادر الطاقه التقليديه من
الوقود الاحفوري بمصادر الطاقه
الفريق الحكومي الدولي المعني بتغيير
المناخ قال انه السبيل لذلك هو تخفيض هذه
الانبعاثات الى النصف بحلول عام 2030 وزي
ما بتقدروا تتخيلوا احنا على بعد سبع
سنوات فقط من هذا التاريخ وما زلنا ابعد
ما نكون عن تحقيق هذا الهدف
من هون جاءت هاي الهبه المفاجئه لايجاد
حلول بديله فالوقت بدا بالفعل ينفذ
ومجاعه بالمحصلات مش بس في منطقه البركان
ولكن على الجانب الاخر من هذا الكوكب
وثوران ايضا بركان جبل بنتوبو في الفلبين
عام 1991 هو اصغر ب 10 مرات من بركان
اندونيسيا ما كانت تبيعاته اكثر اشراقا
على الاطلاق في نهايه المطاف وباعتراف
الفريق الحكومي الدولي معني بتغير المناخ
دهون
علمي لها فانه ضخميات من ثاني اكسيد
الكبريت في طبقات الجو العليا ممكن يتضعف
الرياح الموسميه الصيفيه في افريقيا واسيا
ويؤدي الى جفاف في غابات الامازون على
سبيل المثال للحصر بينما مناطق اخرى من
العالم يمكن انها تستفيد خلصت دراسه حديثه
ايضا الى لانه التحكم الاشعاعي الشمس ممكن
ينجح في تخفيض فرص حدوث جفاف في جنوب
افريقيا بشكل كبير مع انه نحكي عم نحكي عن
التاثير على الانسان انا عارفه انه هذا
يمكن مش مجال اختصاصك الط علم النفسي وكذا
ولكن يعني انا يعني ما بقدر همم
اتغاضى عن نقطه مهمه جدا بنسمع دائما
باوروبا انه في ارتفاع في نسبه الاكتئاب
عند همم
المواطنين او الناس اللي عايشين في اوروبا
بسبب لانه ما بيشوفوا الشمس بسبب ال ااه
الاجواء الماطره
والغائم دائما
وهدك بيؤدي لا زياده همم حالات الانتحار
بشكل كبير هذا الحكي في اوروبا وفي دول
معين بينما هو الاسره والحمد لله احنا كنا
دائما زرقاء جميله وتقص جميل جدا وبنستمتع
بالضبط الشمس
كلنا بالاكتئاب ويمكن ننتحر جماعيا مثلا
بدون شمس وبنفس الوقت كمان الشمس اهم
مصادر الفيتامين دال او فيتامين دال اللي
احنا بحاجه لانه لكل اعضاءنا طيب شو راح
يصير في هذا الموضوع كمان هل ممكن العرضه
لامراض كثير اهمها السرطان
بسبب نقص هذا الفيتامين بسبب نقص اشعه
الشمس
بكل تاكيد ليس فقط الفيتامين دين احنا
اللي بناخذه من الشمس فيتامينات عديده جدا
كل معظم معظم الفيتامينات اللي عم نخدها
من من كلا من كل المزروعات ومن كل الخضار
ومن كل الفاكهه هي مصدره الاساسي الشمس
والانسان بيحارب بيحاجب المطلق للشمس
لالحميه وايضا الشمس بتقتل بتقتل فيرسات
بتقتل الامراض خطيره جدا ولكن نحن بنغير
كل الحقيقه الكوكب بهذه الطريقه عم بنغير
ابن الجذور راح ويكون في نتائج هتكون
مذهله وخطيره جدا مع العلم انه بيقفي دول
في ناس عديده بسبب بسبب تغير تغير الانماط
الغازات الموجوده بالجو بالطريقه اما معين
اتحول دماغ الانسان من دماغ سليم والدماغ
محبه الى دماغ قتل وشر وتدمير وانتحار
وائل اخره ولذلك لهم احنا الانسان
عايش برفاهيه عايش بارتياح كامل بسلام
كامل بمحبه كامل بصحه كامله باينه ما عم
نشوف اماكن لما نشوف في تلوث وفي اشياء
خطيره جدا في في كائن حي الانسان وكل
كائنات حيه بدفعوا الثمن بسم حياتهم
بصحتهم بامراضهم لا سمح الله واشياء اشياء
كثير خطيره طيب دكتور تحدثت عن طبقه
الاوزون اكثر من مره كيف راح تتاثر وخصوصا
انه لما نعرف انه طبقه الاذن الحمد لله
يعني بالكاد ها بلشت تتعافى ووو وتعالج
نفسها اذا اذا اعتمدناها اسلوب الهندسيه
هون هون الخطر الاكبر ما راح نعرف
طريقه التفاعل قبل التجربه قبل التجربه
قبل ما يكون نشوف شو راح
يتصاعد نحو العلم من من الكميات
المقبوبه بالجو يعني في خطر كتير كتير مع
العلم انه طبقه الاوزون نحنا بلشت كورونا
بلش رجليه
انخفاض خطير جدا
بكميه
استهلاك الوقود الاحفوري كنا عارفين بكل
تاكيد انه طبقه الاوزون بعد يعني
الافضل بشكل كبير كبير وهذا اللي حصل يعني
اليوم نحن طبعه الاوزون بها النجاح اللي
عملته او بلشت بلشت يكون في عندها انقباض
للمسيحيات للشيعه كانت خاليه من الاوزون
هيدا سببها بفتره من الفترات توقف توقف
الصناعه توقف الاستهلاك الوقود الاحفوري
من مس اثر ايجابه على طبقه الاوزون وراح
تتاثر ان لمده خمس سنين بعد منها راح ترجع
راح ترجع تدفع الثمن وراح يرجع يكون في
عنا همم كحد اقصى خمس سنين راح يكون في
عنا بيرجع تدمير ومنهج لها الطبقه الحامي
البشريه جمعاء ديك شكل تاكيد انه هل
المواد البلد تنكب بالجوهر بكل تاكيد بده
يكون في تفاعل والخطر الاكبر الخطر الاكبر
في حال الاوزون صار في التعادل نور الشمس
على هذا على طبعه الاوزون»
هل سلبي ولا ايجابي وبشدد على نقطه
اشعه الشمس راح اتاثر علي
وتدمر طبعا بهذا المتركه لا بعد تنفيذها
العمل في حال حصل
طب دكتور مع انه موضوع ال جي وان جينيرانج
او الهندسه الجيولوجيه والبيئيه والشمسيه
مش موضوع جديد يعني له فتره بتم الحديث
فيه يمكن باخر كم سنه اكتسب زخم كثير مع
هيك او زخم كبير مع هيك ما في يعني اي
قوانين في غياب تام لا قوانين سواء كانت
دوليه او محليه في الدول المختلفه وغياب
حتى لا موجود هذا الموضوع همم من خلال
الاتفاقيات الدوليه همم بشكل كبير
فبالتالي هذا بيخلي شو اللي شو اللي ممكن
يمنع همم شخص مثل الجيت مليونير
حتى او شخص مثل ماسك همم او اي شركه صغيره
مثل المايك صن سيتي انها تعمل تجارب من
هذا النوع همم لا ايمانهم لانه هي ممكن
تكون ناجحه
ليش ما فيش هلا ليه ما في قوانين تحكم
موضوع الهندسه الجيولوجيه
نحن طالبنا
طلبنا من كل الجهات الدوليه
جيد جدا لكل مشاكل البيئه بالعالم
اليوم اي حدا بيقدر يطلع يعمل اي عمل
وبيمشي فيه ولك اليوم المفروض تدخل دول
الكبرى بدراسه وبدراسه
جدا من خلال العلماء البيئه والابحاث اللي
عنده
عمل بده يصيب الكتل الهوائيه بده يصيب
المايك وتسيب قلب الارض
واي عمل اي عمل بده ينعمل يكون مدروس بشكل
فعلي جدا مع العلم انه اول شرط ندلنا
محافظين على وصول اشعه الشمس الى كوكب
الارض بشكل مباشر دول اي عوائق مهما كانت
الاسباب طيب معناتها معناها هيك انه الحل
الوحيد اللي قدامنا هو الحل اللي ورد في
اتفاقيه باريس للمناخ عام 2016 لانه نخفض
الانبعاثات الكربونيه والغازات الدفيئه
همم في الارض يعني كانت الحديث عن انه
لازم يخفض على النصف تقريبا بحلول عام
2030 لحتى نضمن المدرجات حراره الارض ما
تزيد عن درجه ونصف اعلى من مستوياتها قبل
الثوره الصناعيه من 250 ل 300 سنه طيب بس
معنى ذلك بما انه في حديث كبير وتوجه
النحو والهندسه الجيولوجيه همم يعني حجب
اشعه الشمس او تعتيمها نوعا ما هذا يعني
بانه هناك في حاجه لانه نحن بصراحه وهذا
اللي بيخلينا واقعين ما بين اراء متضاربه
ومتناقضه حول هذا الموضوع احنا بصراحه على
ما يبدو غير قادرين على انه نخفض
الانبعاثات الكربونيه عن طريق انهم قلل
استخدام الوقود الاحفوري بالزمن المطلوب
منا طب شو الحل اذا ما عندنا حلول اخرى
والحل بسيط جدا هو تخفيض تخفيض انتاج
كميات الوقود الاحفوري بشكل علمي بدل ما
يكون عندنا نحن اليوم عم ننتج 100 مليون
برميل بترول كل يوم انتم الاثنين برميل او
مليون برميل
والتخفيض يعني اليوم اليوم في حال يخفض
30% فورا كميه استهلاك كميه انتاج الوقود
الاحفوري نحن بنكون فورا وقفنا 30% من
الكرسي الموجوده اليوم الكرسي الموجود هي
بالشكل التالي نحن بحاجه الى تخفيض كميات
كميات الغازات الدفيئه بالجوه في حاله ركن
الكميات الغازات الدفيئه وببلده ونحن
عملنا مشاريع توقيف الاشعه الشمس وتخفيض
ينتج عنها تدمير تدمير كوكب الارض تدمير
البيئه تدمير الغيبه تدمير مياه الشرب
تدمير تدمير المناطق الزراعيه ما راح نعرف
انه عارفين انه هالمشروع اللي بنعمل بها
الطريقه راح يدمر راح يدمر هذا الكوكب بدل
ما يكون في اختار هالشكل يتفضل وياخذوا
قرار تقسيط 30 30
قديش هذا الاقتراح يعني
يعني عملي ام لا يعني خلينا نفكر فيها
احنا انت بتحكي عن خساره بلالين الدولارات
من يعني راح تخسرها همم
الوقود السوق الوقود الاحفوري
ومصنعين الوقود الاحفوري وعم نحكي عن دول
اصلا اساس اقتصادها هو البترول فيعني مش
هيكون مش راح يكون قرار سهل ومين راح
يعوضها عن هذه الخساره اذا هي بدها تتبنى
مثل هذه المبادره بانها تخفض الانتاج
وطبعا احنا شفنا في الفتره الاخيره قديش
كان في صعوبه للالتفاق ما بين دول بلاس
على قصه تخفيض الانتاج او زياده الانتاج
بسبب الحرب بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا طيب
يعني
ممكن يعني شخص او ممكن اذا نظرنا لهذا
الاقتراح اللي انت عم تقترحه نحس انه هو
غير عملي وصعب المنال
لا والله
ابدا ولكن يصير عندنا نوع من ارتفاع
الاسعار بتغلط ولكن بطريقه ما من الطرق
بدنا بالاحرى بدنا استراتيجيه بيئيه جديده
لكل دول العالم اليوم بعطيك مثل بسيط
استراتيجيه جديد نحن عم بنشوف في مدينه
مدينه موجوده في الجامعه والمدرسه
والمدارسين
الصبح ياخذوا اولادهم وشبابهم على المدارس
الظهر
[موسيقى]
خلال 20 سنوات او 15 سنه ولكن بشرط تنفيس
تنفيذ الخطه البيئي لحمايه هذا الكوكب طيب
دكتور يعني احد الانتقادات الكبيره على
موضوع استخدام هندسي الجيولوجيه لتخفيض
درجه حراره الارض هو يتخوف متعلق بانه في
حال نجحت جزئيا او كليا ممكن تعطي همم
ذريعه لا همم يعني همم سوق او الاندستري
تبعت الوقود الاحفوري بانه يستمر ما يخفض
الانبعاثات همم الدول كلياتها ما تحاول
انها تخفض الانبعاثات لانه في النهايه
هينا لقينا طريقه ثانيه لحتى نخفض درجات
الحراره بدون ما تخفض ارباحنا همم من
الوقود الاحفوري همم فبالتالي يعني الام
اذا اذا هذا ال- هذا الكلام ممكن همم يعني
همم تجسد هل يمكن ان نوصل لمرحله بحياه
انه غلافنا الجوي واجواء الارض مش بس
مليئه بثانيه اكسيد الكربون ولكن ايضا
مليئه ثاني اكسيد الكب
امال مليئه بالمواد الكيميائيه الاخرى وفي
كل تاكيد هيك حيصير بكل تاكيد هايدي راح
نشوفه وراح نشوف اول ولكن نتائج نتائج
واختاره على الاجيال القادمه محمد بيعرفها
ولا بشكل
فنشق الهواء بدنا نتمشي على الاكسجين نضيف
الهواء نظيف اللي هو الاكسجين 20 و21%
جدا
[موسيقى]
78% النيتروجين صافي هتتغذى عليك كل
الكائنات اخرى
عنصرين عنصر الاكسجين وعنصر النيتروجين
عناصر الهواء الاساسيه نحن تغيرت كل كل كل
اسباب الحياه على كوكب الارض وتغيرت كل
طريقه الكائنات الحيه واذا في حاله ضرب
النيتروجين راح نخسر نباتات بشكل كبير
خطيره صفحه الكوكب وفي حاله انضرب
بالاكسجين نخسر
من الكائنات الحيه بما فيها الانسان
والحيوانات وكل الكائنات تتمشى الغاز
الاكسجين
طيب قبل ما ننهي دكتور كان في مصطلح تكرر
معي خلال بحثي بشكل كبير وهو احد ايضا
الانتقادات او المخاوف فيما يتعلق
باستخدام هاي التكنولوجيا وهذا النوع من
الهندسه اسم التخوف او اسم الفكره
انه كل يعني
الناس اللي منتقدين لهاي الطريقه بيقولوا
بانه حتى لو كانت ناجحه هاي الطريقه مجرد
ما نوقفها لاي سبب من الاسباب في بصير في
اشي اسمه ترميشن شوك يعني صدمه التوقف
وهاي صدمه التوقف رح تخلي درجات حراره
الارض ترتفع وبشكل يعني
وسريع جدا اكثر بكثير من مكان قبل استخدام
هاي الطريقه لحل المشكله
وكل تاكيد بكل تاكيد راح نلاقي راح نلاقي
بلحظه من اللحظات في حاله توقفت او ما عاد
نتج للفعاله او في حال باي ليست بسبب كان
راح نلاقي راح نلاقي تغير مناخي عالمي
خطير جدا الا ابعد الحدود ما بنعرف راح
تكون موجوده لسطح الكوكب من هون نحن بندعي
علماء بيئه انه اخذ العمل الجدي على محمل
الجد من اجل دراسه على وافيه بكل بكل بكل
جوانبها لنقدر اي عمل نقوم فيه بطال
البشريه بيطال الكوكب كله يكون مدروس
بدراسه علميه ميه بالميه ما في اي شوائب
نهائيا ويكون دراسه اثر بيئه لهالموضوع
علمي بامتياز وخاله من كل من كل الكوارث
المستقبليه نتمنى ذلك وبنشكرك جزيل الشكر
دكتور دوميت على وجودك معنا في كلام منطقي
وكل هذه المعلومات القيمه اللي شكرا شكرا
لقناه العربيه اللي فتحت هذا الموضوع على
مصراعيه من خلال حضرتك من خلال البرنامج
وهذا موضوع ان احنا متابعينه من الاول
لاخر لحظه في ختان حلقتنا
ما حدا بيعرف كيف راح تكون حالنا لما نودع
سماءنا الزرقاء ونعيش لسنين تحت سماء
بيضاء بلا لون ونتحمل طبيعه ذلك ايجابيه
كانت ام سلبيه لكن تبقى الهندسه
الجيولوجيه بنظره كثيرين وان كانت ملجانا
الاخير تبقى مثالا حيا على غرور جنسنا
البشري بقدرتنا على تشكيله طبيعه كما يحلو
لنا وفقا لاهوائنا من خلال التكنولوجيا
وهؤلاء باكته انه لا يجب ان تكون هي حل
لكارثه احنا صنعناها بايدينا والان عم
نسعى لاصلاحها
ولكن في المقابل ماذا عسانا ان نفعل
والجواب ممكن انه يكمن في ان ربما لو
اخذنا هاي الكارثه على محمل الجد اكثر
قليلا لاستطعنا تحقيق هدف اتفاقيه باريس
للمناخ ولرايناها كطريقنا الوحيد لتفادي
كوكب بدمر الكربون من جهه وبيعرضوا
الكبريت لخطر كبير من جهه اخرى
وعوضا عن محاوله السيطره على اشعه الشمس
خلينا نركز على تسخيرها لما يخدمنا بحيث
تصبح الالواح الشمسيه وتوربينات الرياح هي
لقاحنا الامثل ضد ارتفاع درجات الحراره
وفي ذات الوقت ضد غطرسه الخوض مجددا في
مغامره هائله لا نعرف عقباها
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيات وانا راويه
العالمي اشكركم ودمتم دائما بامان باذن
الله
[موسيقى]